ce que lionel il a fait les fusées
partie des linkup tu étais le groupe
avec m pokora et au tiff et c'est vrai
que toi parce que tu dois partir donc je
voudrais je devrais te poser deux trois
questions parce que c'est fou ce qui
t'arrive alors tu fais la fin de pop
star ouais donc vous faites le groupe
linkup avec matt pokora et otis et on
vend 750000 disent qu'on est triple
disque d'or ouais l'avenir nous c'est la
folie symphonie way et vous étiez en
difficultés financières avant de
bénéficier du succès des inc cup
ouais voilà donc vous étiez connu mais
avec pas un sou en poche enfin
exactement rien rien donc une cata
ensuite tu expliques que tu as été déçu
par m pokora dans une interview en 2013
fille nikita jamais tendu la main
qu'est-ce qu'il en ait quatre emprunts
parce que max et ce n'est pas le genre
mines dans un c non en fait c'est pas je
reproche rien du tout on est on est
potes on voit assez souvent je suis allé
à son dernier concert je lui
reprocherais après c'est toujours la
déformation des années des magazines
j'ai juste simplement dit j'aurais aimé
faire un duo avec lui voilà pour pour se
rappeler du bon vieux temps histoire de
même même une scène pas revenir sur
scène avec lui partager une chanson j'ai
juste dit ça et ça a été déformé dans la
presse en disant que j'ai je jalouse et
son succès voilà alors lionel juste le
truc c'est qu'il paraît que toi
maintenant dans la rue dès que les gens
les gens y en a plein qui te
reconnaissent ils parlent de quoi il
parle que de ne pas croire ah ouais
ouais ouais c'est à dire dès qu'ils
voient c'est à chaque fois c'est oui
j'aimais bien ta voix mais tu es
toujours quoique avec matt ouais y en a
même un qui m'a qui m'a arrêté dans le
marais il métier mais c'était très
violent me dis mais c'est un looser
tapas tapas la rage que ma très réussi
et toi pas non et là j'étais avec des
potes je me suis mis il vient vraiment
me dire ça quand les gars un démon s'est
fait jeudi mais mais toi tu as vendu des
disques tu as déjà eu un disque d'or
donc il juste et heureux de tout ce que
tu as vécu déjà mais chut mec le plus
heureux après c'est difficile il faut se
renouveler faut travailler tu travailles
pas abeilles à rien maintenant il faut
prendre des cours de théâtre faut
prendre des coups j'aimerais mais tu
t'es content pour matt aujourd'hui bien
sûr je suis très heureux pour lui
je ne jalouse pas c'est mon pote sinon
je peux pas aller le voir à son concert
à bercy
nous les bons et on n'a pas marqué en 10
à chaque fois qu'on me demande des
nouvelles de matt pokora à chaque fois
t'as pas un numéro
on me demande des places diack ailleurs
on vient me parler sur internet ou sur
sur un de sa gamme tu connais ma tu lui
parles encore est ce que tu peux avoir
des places à temps c'est ce que vivent
tous les chroniqueurs de on n'a pas
envie de voir
mais c'est vrai qu'on nous parle souvent
doux et en est un à des places